[Musik]
hallo zusammen ich mache heute mit euch
Baklava Cheesecake Muffins auf die sehr
sehr einfache Art sind richtig cooles
Rezept gerade wenn man so Gäste hat was
cooles auftischen möchte ich glaube das
ist doch richtig für Aufsehen und alle
werden sich richtig wunderbar wow
gezaubert ich starte direkt mit dem
Rezept und suche hier
direkt aufzufrieden also ihr braucht auf
jeden Fall Baklava Teig das ist dieser
sehr sehr feine filo Teig der ist so
fein dass ihr durch gucken könnten
anderer funktioniert hier nicht so gut
und den werde ich jetzt erstmal
zurechtschneiden und verpassen zu meiner
Muffinform
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt mit meinem Süßen
Zollstock einfach ausgemessen wie groß
meine Form ist also einmal den Boden und
die Ränder und ich werde so ein bisschen
überstehen lassen weil das ganz süß
finde also habe ich hier vier Zimmer 14
cm je nachdem wie groß eure Form ist
könnt ihr da natürlich auch ein bisschen
kleiner oder ein bisschen größer eure
Quadrate schneiden das habe ich übrigens
irgendwann mal mir angeschafft weil
haben sie nicht unterwegs nur so
Produktideen haben und dann brauchen wir
immer so ein Zollstock weil wir das
gerade so uns vorstellen möchten so und
jetzt nehme ich mir also wichtig
übrigens ihr nehmt euch das jetzt zwar
gerne aber der Rest sollte unter einem
Küchentuch bleiben weil das sonst
wirklich sehr schnell
aushärtet und und und trocken wird so
und jetzt kann ich ja hier einfach
drüberlegen meine Muffinform ich habe
mir Butter in der Mikrowelle bei
geringer Wattzahl erhitzt und ein
kleiner Geheimtipp ist jetzt noch mal
Butter hier dazu zu tun das ist eher so
bei den Syrern diese syrische Art
Baklava zu machen da gibt's auch immer
buttergie sogar dieses das
gebe ich jetzt noch mit dazu müsst ihr
aber nicht vor allem wenn ihr kein
Butter die mögt dann könnt ihr das auch
weglassen das ist hier jetzt noch drin
schmelzen für diesen typischen
Eigengeschmack von Baklava und dann
nehme ich mir meinen Pinsel und Pinsel
hier einmal die Muffinform ein und dann
könnt ihr euren Filoteig immer Schichten
ihr könnt das auch so ein bisschen
ungerade da reinlegen also richtig so
ein bisschen Falten das soll ruhig
bewusst so ein bisschen akkurat Aussehen
ich finde das nämlich und dann immer
wieder Butter auch hier oben nicht
vergessen damit es nicht trocken wird
dann könnt ihr da jetzt mehrere Lagen
ineinander gebe euch gleich bescheid wie
viele Lagen ist bei mir geworden sind
und dann hat man später diese richtig
schöne Baklava Schale
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt acht lagen Filoteig
jetzt müsst ihr euch aber vorstellen
dass ihr ja am Rand den filotec immer
mal so ein bisschen geknickt habt daher
ist der Rand sehr stabil und hat die
ausreichende Dicke der Boden allerdings
nicht weil der hat ja immer nur so ein
immer nur diese acht flachen federteile
daher nehmt ihr euch jetzt noch mal eine
ihr könnt das auch noch mal so ein
bisschen zurechtschneiden und gibt da
jetzt auch noch mal so zwei drei vier
lagen auf dem Boden einfach damit wir
unten noch die nötige Stabilität haben
immer natürlich ein bisschen Butter in
die Zwischenschichten so und dann mache
ich so weiter bis mein ganzes machen
gleich einfach voll ist
[Musik]
so fertig sind die Baklava Cups Ofen
habe ich vorgeheizt auf 190 Grad Ober
und Unterhitze und jetzt werden die
goldbraun gebacken
so fertig gebacken 15 Minuten hat das
ganze bei mir gedauert es kann sein dass
ihr 14 oder 16 Minuten benötigt schaut
auf jeden Fall dass die schön goldbraun
sind nicht zu hell denn wenn sie richtig
schön tiefen goldbraun sind dann könnt
ihr euch sicher sein dass nichts anheben
dass er auch an der Seite hell goldbraun
sind und dann sind sie perfekt sie soll
natürlich nicht zu blass sein und jetzt
solange sie noch warm sind drücke ich
hier einfach mit einem Gegenstand ich
habe bisschen mein Kochlöffel einfach
runter damit ich gleich einfach noch ein
bisschen mehr Platz habe für meine
Cheesecake Masse könnt ihr am besten
wenn es noch warmes ins kaltes gestaltet
sich das ein bisschen schwierig das
knackt ein bisschen das ist aber gar
nicht schlimm weil ja einfach mal mein
Video gecrasht
auch richtig geil ja wenn die Leute
jetzt sagen warum isst du denn während
Ramadan da müssen wir ja weil das da
wundern sich auch manche wir drehen ein
paar Videos vor
ein paar Videos vor heute den 25 Januar
dran
okay keiner Ereignisse im Kalender ja
wunderbar so jetzt noch ein
entscheidender Tipp löst am besten eure
Baklava Förmchen noch warm also nicht
unbedingt ganz ganz heiß aber auf keinen
Fall abgekühlt weil sonst setzt sich das
richtig fest weil die Butter ja auch
fest wird also schön noch warm lösen und
dann vollständig auskühlen lassen
[Musik]
und die Cheesecake Masse ist simpel aber
genial genauso wie ich liebe dafür
braucht ihr auch nur ganz wenige Zutaten
ich habe hier Doppelrahmfrischkäse dann
nehme ich zum Beispiel ganz gerne
Philadelphia original dann nehme ich mir
hier eine saubere neue Schüssel die im
besten Fall sogar kalt ist weil es
schlagen uns Schlagsahne auf kalte
Schlagsahne frisch aus dem Kühlschrank
mach das schnell mit dem Handrührgerät
und dann ist mein Geheimtipp gleich zur
Cheesecake Masse also zu Frischkäse
Gelierzucker mit dazu zu geben ihr könnt
auch normalen Zucker verwenden oder
Puderzucker wenn ihr das schnell
servieren möchtet bei Zucker ist einfach
der Unterschied das ist die Kristalle
die lösen sich halt mit der Zeit auf
Gelierzucker hat noch mal den Vorteil
dass wenn es kühlt das einfach die
Konsistenz ein bisschen fester
unangenehmer ist aber Puderzucker könnt
ihr verwenden wenn ihr das sofort
servieren möchte weil das müsste sich
halt sofort in der Feuchtigkeit auf das
dazu falls ihr noch weitere Fragen habt
schreibt sie immer unten in die
Kommentare und ich schlage jetzt hier
Sahne zusammen mit Sahnefest und ein
bisschen Vanille nicht auf
[Musik]
die Frischkäse Masse bitte nur ein paar
Sekunden verrühren mit dem Gelierzucker
oder halt den Zucker oder den
Puderzucker das ist ja euch überlassen
und jetzt nehme ich mir ein Teigschaber
und hebt die Sahne hier einfach unter
das geht auch super schnell ich muss
sagen die ist innerhalb von 5 Minuten
zusammen gerührt aber was ist hier
wirklich ausmacht ist einmal dass ihr
Salz Armen Frischkäse verwendet also
jetzt nicht unbedingt ähm das ist oft so
bei No Name Marken muss ich sagen oder
bei bestimmten Marken das schmeckt der
Frischkäse schon sehr salzig dann
finde ich immer hatte so einen komischen
beige Geschmack und was hier auch
ausschlaggebend ist ist natürlich die
Vanille also Vanilleextrakt muss
eigentlich sein sonst habt ihr wirklich
nur so ein käsigen sahnigen Geschmack
ohne halt was besonderes dabei daher
unbedingt da nicht sparen und mit
reingeben ich verlinke euch meinen auf
jeden Fall
unten in die Infobox und es ist
alkoholfrei müssen heutzutage auch nicht
mehr selbstverständlich und das werde
ich mir gleich in einen Spritzbeutel
umfüllen du kannst einfacher einzeln ihr
könnt auch zwei Löffel immer so einfach
easia
[Musik]
ich muss sagen ich finde die sehen schon
echt richtig richtig süß aus ich mache
jetzt hier noch einfach on top Pistazien
schön fein hacken und dann einfach wie
so Streusel oben drüber geben und jetzt
dürft ihr nicht denken dass irgendwie
durchweichen oder so also es bleibt
schon noch sehr knackig ihr könnt das
also guten paar Stunden oder auch morgen
schon für abends vorbereiten die werden
auch am nächsten Tag noch schmecken dass
definitiv daher stresst euch da nicht
und bereitet sie gerne im Vorfeld vor
und wenn ich die Pistazien noch drauf
gebe bin ich eigentlich tun und
zufrieden weil natürlich nicht nur
geschmacklich aber auch optisch macht es
einfach jetzt noch mal was her dass du
so ein bisschen Grün ist erinnert ja
auch wieder so ein Orient und dann sind
sie auch schon fertig
[Musik]
wir sind eingeladen beim Besuch das wird
auch richtig als Nachtisch was denkst du
boah die Frau kann gut backen
schöne Blumen Rosen das machen
oh mein Gott wie hast du das gemacht
ohne Zuckersirup weil die süße steckt im
Cheesecake so froh dass es heute 15:49
Uhr ist und wir Roboter danach alle
haben und ich habe essen kann also es
ist jetzt nicht Ramadan aber es war es
ist jetzt aber online geht sind
so doof ist
[Musik]
das Weg knutschen
oh nein
[Gelächter]
aber es schmeckt mega lecker
ich muss
mal schmeckt natürlich
tun
sehr stark
verwendet bei mir war es jetzt genau
richtig ich finde es echt geil Leute es
ist das beste ist es sieht wirklich
nicht schwer Magen und das ist finde ich
abends auch echt wichtig ne wenn man
sich schon bisher gönnt das ist so
locker weil das ist wirklich lecker
[Musik]
natürlich
die orientischen Varianten von den
letzten Jahren an wir hatten Baklava
Cheesecake letztes Jahr als Torte dann
hatte ich schon mal in meinen Kochbuch
geschafft weil es so geil war also ich
habe generell so viele fusionsrezepte
weil ich liebe Cheesecake also ich gönne
mir das jetzt auch ohne Kamera weil das
kann man das kann man nicht so Elefant
ne so ein bisschen rosa bis zum nächsten
Mal machen nachmachen
[Musik]